hello there guys and welcome to another
commentary video in this commentary
video we're going to go over
everything we know about season 2 of the
mandalorian
before we jump into the video the
question of the day is
are you guys excited for mandalorian
season 2 and what do you hope to see
please let me know in the comment
section below with that out of the way
let's get straight into the video
season one of the mandalorian ended on a
cliffhanger after successfully
retrieving baby yoda from off gideon and
his scout troopers the mandalorian is
toured by the armorer to guard the child
with his life the armorer also tells
mando to research the child
and find his people this is likely the
journey we'll follow in season 2. we
also learnt that morph gideon survived
his fight with the mandalorian
it also wields the darksaber and yeah
guys i'm actually
really curious on um how moth gideon has
the darksaber and
what it means to him because you know
the last person we saw after darkstable
was bogotan and rebels
did she die did moffke then get it off
her but i'm sure we'll get some answers
on how he um
came to after darksaber anyway so season
two of the mandalorian will release on
october 30th
according to entertainment weekly there
will once again be eight episodes
of varying lamps season two will also
pick up where season one left off i
actually really like um that season two
will pick off with season one left off
because it seems like the main alone is
going to be one continuous
long story i actually did hear a rumor
that episode one of season two will be
titled
chapter nine so you know in season one
you know the episodes were titled as
chapters so episode one was chapter one
and
episode two was chapter 2 and so forth
so um
it looks like they're maybe continuing
this trend and be climbing up to
chapters as one continuous long story
anyway so who will join the cast of
season two
so um nothing is confirmed yet although
there is enough evidence
to make us pretty confident that these
things will indeed happen
so according to slash film rosario
dawson will play a live-action version
of ahsoka tano
this is actually a rumor that dawson
herself has heavily hinted
in past interviews as being true slash
film has
also reported that kd sakhoff will play
the live-action version
of another animated character bo katan
a character she voiced in the clone wars
and rebels
timothy olihamph has also apparently
joined their cast
and will play a character who wears boba
fett's armor
okay so this is really interesting to me
because in the
aftermath novels there was a character
in the book that it was apparently
wearing
bounty hunter armor similar to um boba
fett so it's possible in season two
we'll see an episode where possibly the
mandalorian will help boba fett retrieve
his armor
which could be a pretty cool and
interesting episode but you know
i guess we'll just have to wait and see
anyway michael bean was also cast as a
bounty hunter according to the hollywood
reporter
also tamarra morrison who is obviously
rumored to play boba fett is
also rumored to play the role of captain
rex
so all these rumors are really exciting
i hope they end up being true
one of the actors from the show pretty
sure cara doon
actually said that these rumors some of
them actually true
personally for me i really hope ahsoka
and boba fett will end up being the
rooms that are true
um and if we get all of them and that's
even better but yeah those are the two
characters that i really want to see
return in season two of the amanda
lauren but yeah that's pretty much
everything we know about season two of
amanda lauren um we don't know
too much not much details have been
revealed we have only received one
trailer so far
and to be honest it's kind of more of
like a teaser trailer because it didn't
really reveal too much
of the story and stuff but i'm sure
we'll get at least
one more trailer before the release of
season two but anyway guys that's pretty
much everything for this commentary
video so please like subscribe and share
the video if you guys enjoy it and i'll
see you guys in the next video
[Music]
you